US Secretary of State John Kerry arrives in India for a three-day visit...
...to co-chair the US-India strategic and commercial dialog.
In Brazil, suspended President Dilma Rousseff...
...told the senate her ongoing impeachment trial is an attack...
...on the country's constitution and claims her innocence.
In Yemen, Houthi forces are firing rockets...
...into the Saudi Arabian border town of Najran,...
...the latest wave killing 29 civilians and complicating peace talks.
In Estonia, there is no clear winner...
...in the first round of  presidential elections launched  by the parliament.
The second round will be held tomorrow.
And finally from Iraq, an Islamic State group claims responsibility...
...for a bomb attack on August 28 at a wedding party in Karbala...
...that killed at least 15 people.